du cinéma avec la sortie demain sur les
écrans des portes de la gloire a réalisé
par christian merret palmair avec benoît
poelvoorde
celui qui interprétait les rôles
dérangeant mais plein d'humour dans les
randonneurs où c'est arrivé près de chez
vous incarne cette fois un vrp plein de
rêves de grandeur présentation pascal
deschamps est-ce que vous avez
l'impression justement que vous avez une
tête et un nom qui font venir les gens
au cinéma
maintenant après trois films quasi culte
et une solide réputation d'amuseur hors
norme la tête de benoît poelvoorde passe
encore l'époque et c'est tant mieux
les portes de la gloire sont celles qui
espèrent franchir l'équipe de vrp qu'il
dirige
un scénario qu'il a coécrit avec ses
deux complices de toujours
mélange comme toujours de tendresse et
de cruauté sur certaines réalités n'est
pas ici pour les plaindre ou pour leur
dire qu'ils sont de la merde tu es ici
pour leur part de la merde et les
féliciter large choisi la rue ok sympa
c'est que après l'avoir vu les gens
aient un peu de compassion quand les
gens viennent sonner en attendant
peut-être aider la profession à avoir
les portes qui s'ouvrent un peu plus
vite ce n'est pas évident on est pour
tous plus facilement
chez deux way à l'un d'eux ah oui
c'est le contraste entre le sérieux des
personnages et le ridicule des
situations qui donne au film son ton
décalé je vous ai préparé quelques mises
en situation américaine et après vous
aurez quartier est ce que tu m'as vu
ouvrir la porte
est ce que quelqu'un m'avait ouvrir sept
d'or c'est à l'exercice et il a fait ses
preuves aux états unis qui a pour thème
on a jamais deux fois l'occasion de
faire une bonne première agression
imagine que tu fait bonne impression
autres malades attendaient des genres de
pénis et de finis stratégie à
l'américaine et ses signes mais on avait
dit au montage attend six minutes les
gens n'ont pas rigolé six minutes en
train de tuer le gag
quand on l'a vu projeté mais c'est
hallucinant alors j'ai fait la première
projection j'avais vu avec mon épouse à
côté de moi et sincèrement munichois je
suis ridicule que sans maillot bourré de
références cinématographiques le film ne
se prend jamais au sérieux les portes de
la gloire blague de potache non dénuée
de profondeur va largement d'être
repoussée